طالبت نقابه اطباء السودان اطراف النزاع
بمنع الوجود المسلح في المرافق الطبيه او
قربها ورفضت في بيان اي وجود عسكري مسلح
داخل المؤسسات الطبيه المدنيه وقالت ان
الوجود العسكريه داخل المؤسسات الطبيه او
استخدامها كمنصات للقصف يحولها لساحه
معركه واشارت الى انها تعالج المصابين من
الطرفين المتنازعين ولا تسمح لاي طرف
بالتدخل في القرار المهني
من مستشفى احمد قاسم في الخرطوم في
الخرطوم بحري ينضم الينا محمد طيب محمد
القطاع الطبي كان من اكثر من عانوا من هذه
المواجهات وبالتالي طبعا المواطن السوداني
في نهايه المطاف
نعم معاناه القطاع الطبي عموما هنا في
الخرطوم بحري والخرطوم ايضا
معقده بحكم انقطاع التيار الكهربائي هو
واحده من الازمات التي تواجه القطاع الطبي
الوصول الى المستشفيات بالنسبه الى
بالنسبه للاطباء
وانقطاع الامداد الدوائي هذا جزء من
الازمات التي تواجه القطاع الطبي هنا في
ظل هذه الازمه نحن الان في مستشفى احمد
قاسم المتخصص
للكلى وجدنا ان الطاقم منذ بدايه هذه
الازمه لم يغادر المستشفى وظل يقدم خدماته
للناس
وللمحتاجين ولهذه الخدمات والمشاكل التي
تواجه هذا القطاع كبيره نتعرف عليها مع
الدكتور طارق نادره مدير الطبي للمستشفى
ما هي الازمات التي تواجهكم هنا في
المستشفى في تقديم الرع الطبيه والله بسم
الله الرحمن الرحيم اول حاجه يعني عندنا
المشكله بتاعه الانقطاع المتكرر للكهرباء
واللي هو بيتطلب منه يكون محتاجين ملتقات
بتروليه زي الجهاز عشان اشغلها
بنحاول دائما يعني نوفر الحاجه دي قدر ما
نقدر طبعا انت عارف برا الظروف
مشكله يعني الحاجه التانيه في مشكله غسيل
الكلى طبعا انقطع التيار الكهربي والمويه
باسرعلى غسيل الكلى انه محتاج كهرباء
ومحتاج مويه
وعندنا مشكله المستهلكات بتاعتك بتاعت
الغسيل يعني احنا وصلنا ما عندنا طوارئ
بتاعه غسيل هنا لكن طبعا الظروف الحاليه
المستشفى التي تستقبل اي زول ما قاعد يظهر
المركز بتاعه قادر الامكان بنحاول نغسل
الكلى للناس كلهم لانه موضوع غسيل الكلى
يعني اذا تاخر في الغسيل بتاعه بتبقى له
مشكله كبيره وعندها مضاعفات كثيره جديده
يعني لكن الاستهلاك الكثير ده زي ما
بيقولوا هو اثر على الاسطوك بتاعنا في
المستشفى
وبنحاول قدر الامكان هسه انه يعني عشان
نغسل الناس كلهم لانه الموضوع خطير شديد
يعني ما هي نداءاتكم يعني اي جهه معنيه
فيما يتعلق بالمسارات الامنه فيما يتعلق
بنقص الامداد الدوائي خاصه للذين يزرعون
الكلى يحتاجون الى نوعيه معينه من الدواء
يجب ان يتعاطوها باستمرار حتى لا يفقدون
حياتهم ايوه طبعا هو موضوع زراعه الكلى
ذاته هو يعني زي ما نقولوا عشان يعني يقدر
يزرع الكلى هو موضوع صعب شويه
فدائما زي ما بيقولوا الادويه حقت المناعه
هي المهمه عشان الجسم ما يرفض الكلى فهي
زي ما نقولوا ادويه زراعه الكلى بيساوي
حياه زارعه الكلى يعني فيعني زين كل
الجهات توفر لنا المستهلكات الغسيل
والادويه حق الزراعه الكلى وكل المستهلكات
الطبيه عشان نقدر نواصل زي ما نقولوا يعني
خدمه الناس في الظروف دي يعني الناس
يقولوا بتتحرك يا الله ويا امين في
السودان يعني عشان تقدر تصنف ما ممكن
يصلون هنا ويقول حاجات ناقصه ولا كذا
بنحاول قدر الامكان ونوفر الحاجات دي عشان
نساعد الناس ونخدمهم زي ما بقولوا يعني
سؤال اخير كم حجم التغطيه الذي يغطيه هذا
المستشفى مقارنه اللي في المنطقه عموما
والله في الوضع الحالي زي ما بيقولوا
تقريبا مغطي زي ما نقولوا بحري كلها يعني
محلات بحري كلها ما عندي علم بالمستشفيات
شغاله التانيه لكن يعني يعني حتى
المستشفيات شغاله معظم كثيره
في كل المستشفيات ما عندنا احنا هنا بس
يعني هم يعني
حاسين بالتعب شديد يعني
مغطية يعني
شريحه كبيره شهيد في ظل الوضع الحالي يعني
شديد يعني فبنتمنى بس انه الحياه دي توفر
زي ما نقولوا عشان نقدر نواصل يعني ان شاء
الله شكرا دكتور طارق عثمان كما سمعت
النداءات المستشفى تتحدث على احتياجات
تتعلق
بتوفير الوقود
للكهرباء توفير الامدادات الطبيه المتعلقه
المتخصصه والادويه المتخصصه
لزارعي الكلاب بالاضافه الى توفير
المعينات ولوحدات
المعدات الخاصه والمواد الخاصه
لوحدات غسيل الكلى هذا هو شكل الموقف هنا
في هذا المستشفى ولعله يشابه عدد
اخر من المستشفيات التي تعاني من نفس
الازمات نقص الامداد وانقطاع التيار
الكهربائي عثمان نعم نتمنى ان تصل الرساله
وان يساعد الاطباء والممرضون على القيام
بعملهم بلا شك شكرا جزيلا لك محمد الطيب
كان معنا من مستشفى احمد قاسم في الخرطوم
بحري